[Música]
o conceito de cidade de 15 minutos e
para onde caminha o trabalho híbrido
velho novo normal os ambientes das
empresas é o tema que vamos discutir
aqui cite algo que a pandemia trouxe
para todo mundo e o mundo todo ao mesmo
tempo foi a necessidade de implementar
políticas flexíveis de trabalho seja ela
até de trabalho trabalho em casa ou
mesmo mas tá variando aí o tipo de
escritório e como são ofertados em
serviços para os colaboradores Mas uma
coisa é certa o futuro Mudou as relações
interpessoais com colegas Paris
Vingadores e fornecedores nunca mais
serão as mesmas e Vamos zuar bastante
desse conceito hoje aqui a cada década a
humanidade nossa sociedade passa por
transformações fortes sejam elas
tecnológicas ou culturais que forçam que
os ambientes de trabalho não seja mais o
mesmo né a gente voltar nos anos 80 Rua
invenção ali né do básico da informática
da eletrônica com a chegada das TVs em
massa colorida dos telefones do fax né
fez com que isso mudasse né as empresas
tinham que se acostumar com essa
digitalização que começou a existir
ainda né de maneira Digamos um pouco
analógica mas interagir com essa questão
eletrônica dos equipamentos anos 90 foi
a chegada dos dispositivos de
comunicação remota os primeiros
telefones celulares os peixes que não
lembra da quando os peixes e também
fizeram com que as empresas adotassem em
massa essa
internet nos anos 2000 chegada dos
Notebooks a finalzinho dos anos 90
chegada do desktop internet para todo
mundo a digitalização em massa e 2000 a
chegada desse computador de mesa ou
notebook né que ajudou O que as empresas
tivessem uma mobilidade nos seus
ambientes de trabalho também né E ali
começou a se cogitar um pouquinho sobre
essa oportunidade de trabalhar em casa
não tá lá em casa e tudo mais ano de
2010 para frente a chegada dos
smartphones e dos tablets não é o iPhone
que é recente de 2007 o mesmo né o
sistema Android aí do ano seguinte mas
mesmo assim né a chegada em massa dos
dispositivos inteligentes de mão como
chamamos fez com que as empresas
redesenhar assim né todo seu ambiente de
trabalho em 2020 com a chegada da
academia infelizmente algumas
tecnologias e ressaltaram Isso mudou
Somente trabalho entre elas né as
videoconferências como todos nós as
ligações para aplicativo né mas também o
trabalho flexível
necessidade de estar presencialmente no
escritório necessariamente Porque meu
chefe quer né mas foi uma questão
sanitária que nos Forçou a estar em casa
mas com certeza tem um bom legado né as
empresas estão mudando tanto que nos
últimos anos a gente viu o tempo de vida
das empresas mudar de maneira muito
drástica na lembrancinha de 20 por
exemplo sempre será feita para durar 70
anos passar de uma geração para outra se
diz avô para pai para filho para o neto
nos anos de 2010 uma empresa tem uma
expectativa de vida de 15 anos enquanto
agora em 2020 expectativa de vida de uma
empresa caiu para 8 anos Isso mesmo a
gente imagina a venda é porque uma Emily
Ei a gente colocava no Bispo é no plano
de negócio de 10 anos esse já não mais
existe se uma empresa feita para durar 8
anos para homem que ela já tem que
entregar né uma
não equilibrada de caixa de resultado no
seu segundo ano porque ela vai ter
poucos anos para entregar né tudo aquilo
que ela se propôs a fazer se essa
expectativa de vida das empresas estão
mudando esse interfere também com
certeza mesmo tipo de ambiente de
trabalho outra coisa tem polícia no
muito saber de trabalho são os tipos de
empresas que estão crescendo muito se
voltasse lá em 1999 pegar essas
principais empresas que estão listadas
na bolsa provavelmente encontraria um
mix entre empresas de óleo e gás empresa
de manufatura e algumas empresas de
tecnologia e se eu voltar agora
provavelmente todas as principais
consequências das top 10 vou ser
empresas de tecnologia e serviços de
informação não necessariamente produtora
de hardware né mas se empresas que usam
o seu serviço e a falta de informação e
inteligência artificial Big Data a
serviço dos seus clientes estão isso
Areado com essa transformações trabalho
que a gente tá vendo esse modelo híbrido
que todo mundo já sabe o que que é tá
criando um conceito novo esse conceito
novo essa cidade de 15 minutos essa
cidade onde as pessoas querem estar
próximas a 15 minutos de qualquer coisa
que você precisa realizar ali próximo de
você seja uma escola deixar seu filho
com seu trabalho Felipe no shopping
lazer né então a necessidade de
mobilidade Que nós tínhamos no passado
entre você ficar uma hora 2 horas no
trânsito para chegar no trabalho eu
pegar aquele transporte público pesado
foi desafiada com a pandemia Se tem uma
coisa que eu mostre trouxe trouxe de
maneira muito inteligente foi que não
existe mais a necessidade da gente se
deslocar por longo prazo mas eu vou mas
se não funciona para todo mundo nem todo
mundo tem o privilégio de fazer almoço e
como ele sabe o rapaz escreveu apenas
uma parcela da população né mas se ao
invés de fazer com que todo mundo se
desloca né
suburbanas para o centro das grandes
cidades sobretudo cidades médias para
trabalhar numa matriz para que estudar
faz sentido né Será que pegar o meu
carro e tem que andar 14 km para chegar
no hospital mais próximo da faz sentido
Será que eu não encontrar as coisas no
meu bairro que meu bairro é Residencial
e na característica que ele vai vai vai
decidir o futuro o conceito de cidade de
15 minutos tá aí para mim salvar a
cidade de 15 minutos não necessariamente
vão sobreviver se não estiverem
inseridas no conceito da nova economia a
economia 4.0 economia compartilhada que
alguns Pilares tá pessoal então vamos lá
primeiro Pilar da economia compartilhada
é lógico né A questão social a questão
de
tribalizado você colaborar né de você
compartilhar aquele ativo aquela
experiência aquele serviço com amigos
com outros usuários nem lembra gente dos
patinetes lembra das bicicletas que
ganharam as ruas em seus momentos de
várias pessoas compartilhavam o mesmo
que o meu
Então isso é a base da economia da
salada também comia colaborativas na
minha compartilhada para questão social
comunidade muito forte né Essa questão
tribal essa questão do organizar e
cuidar por parte do usuário quem era o
principal
fiscal dos patinetes usuários apontavam
defeito não a empresa está fazendo a
supervisão Então pensa nessa questão
outro Pilar muito forte pela financeiro
Lógico né tem que ter ganho tem que ser
mais barato tem que ter menos risco eu
não vou ter a propriedade né multi valor
pago em várias moedas mas as digitais e
físicas né eu tenho que ver os
resultados de curto prazo eu quero quero
agora tem que tar instantâneo esse ganho
né se a gente pega a Geração 6 já tá na
mente de trabalho é uma geração
imediatista é uma geração que que tem os
benefícios Agora não dá para ir para a
vida inteira para comprar o carro de
luxo que é usufruto agora e ela tem
usufruir numa outra modalidade né que eu
não é economia
visto ele vai esperar um pouquinho mais
daqui a pouco eu te contei só para
avisar os outros dois pilares da
economia compartilhada a questão
cultural a economia compartilhada tem
que trazer impacto na cultura seja ele
da sociedade para a gente vir se ele
trazer o Dindo visão matéria-prima né a
economia criativa como um todo a gente
vê esses grande unicórnios né esses
novos serviços que apareceram é porque
eles tinham essa questão enraizada pode
vir grandes Startup mesmo que elas
cresçam e se tornem grandes empresas ela
não tem aquele viés de Startup por
último o Pilar ambiental não tem como a
gente falar de cidade de 15 minutos nova
economia senti no Face impacto no meio
ambiente de hoje se a pandemia com o ser
humano no centro da crise não tem como a
gente sair dessa crise sem ser humano
não tem como ser humano se cuidar do
meio ambiente vai então economia
compartilhada exatamente para diminuir o
uso de recursos é exatamente para
garantir que tá sendo maximizado o uso
de determinados ativos e com isso uma
infraestrutura gente isso vai fazer com
que a gente tem o impacto ambiental
muito menor ou mesmo Positivo tá então
esses quatro pilares da economia
compartilhada é uma base da cidade de 15
minutos uma mudança drástica no perfil
também do usuário é o consumidor deixa
de consumir e comprar marca porque é
chique porque ele quer e ele passa seu
usuário ele usa marca né daquela marca
serve para ele tá legal semana depois
ele trocar de marca ele ele não tem mais
aquela fidelidade passou aquela época
que as pessoas tatuavam a marca do ativo
porque ela era fã daquilo não ela vai de
acordo com a onda e hoje as pessoas não
se contentam mais com storytelling não
adianta você ir para internet falar que
é sustentável mas essas suas ações não é
sustentável o Executivo anda no carro
que polui é ruim mesmo a empresa não
implementa né coisas sustentáveis e
ações sustentáveis dentro do seu dia a
dia então quando ele fala também de
cidade 15 minutos para alugar em
tecnologia a questão da Smart City
Cidade do Futuro tudo conectado internet
das coisas né Big deitar não vou tomar
esse conceito de Deus muita gente falou
mas cada vez mais a tecnologia é a base
né Ela é a ferramenta que faz com que a
gente possa se entender esse conceito de
tudo próximo com 15 minutos você Já
pensaram no dia que chegasse todos os
carros foram todos esses carros tem que
conversar com um semáforo você vai poder
conversar com o centro de controles está
passando uma ambulância ali tem que dar
aquela preferência o carro autônomo ele
vai depender de saber o que os outros
carros que não são todos que estão
fazendo então até que o logia é com tudo
isso que a gente vê né nos dias de hoje
vai ser a base da cidade de 15 minutos a
economia da experiência também afinal de
contas a gente não vai ter mais ativo a
gente vai usufruir ativa a gente que tem
essa experiência Gourmet tização a
experiência é isso traz facilidade isso
faz com que a mercadoria chegue na minha
mão muito antes e aí só para explorar
para você só um pouquinhos desde quinze
minutos o trabalho aí Brito ele é sim
salgado os componentes Então você não
vai ter horário para trabalhar esse
horário vai ser flexível e vai trabalhar
nas horas que te convém não vai ter
Jornada para trabalhar você trabalha no
dia da semana aqui faça um sentido para
Sua Entrega a sua localização vai ser
flexível no dia de casa um dia
escritório o dia de um corpo ou trabalha
na cafeteria próximo de casa e você vai
definir de acordo com a tecnologia com a
sua necessidade Qual o seu ponto de
trabalho a sua remuneração é ser
flexível de acordo com a sua entrega e a
sua gestão e seco base em clipe aê
performance não mais aquela gestão para
trás a Melody chefe precisava ver as
pessoas para confiar nas pessoas ou
aquele escritório fica lá perto da casa
do chefe que o chefe morava ali e fazer
com que todo mundo se deslocasse para
escritório só que ele morava mais perto
né Isso não vai fazer mais sentido nesse
conceito de cidade de 15 minutos os
escritórios vão ser inundados
experiências com centro de
relacionamento das pessoas vão
escritório para trocar né e terça a
interface entre eles fazer essa
lateralidade mas a gente vai ter pelo
menos seis tipos de usuários distintos
no escritório aquele cara que vem todo
dia pessoal que tá lá só para durante um
projeto aquele cara que vai de vez em
quando aquele cara que é viajante que tá
passando por aquela semana aquele
trabalho de casa e aquele dia foi
visitar o escritório e aquele cara que
já tá no modelo híbrido né que muita
gente foi contratado por Job e que tá
ali só dá um pequeno período e os
escritórios amanhã vão precisar né da
cidade 15 minutos tá preparados para
receber todo mundo né ele fez uma
pesquisa recente né fiz uma pesquisa
recente perdão onde boa parte dos
entrevistados deixaram claro que eles
preferem irmão ambiente de trabalho não
mais que duas a três vezes por semana e
os outros dias ele gostaria que tivesse
essa flexibilidade até porque as
prioridades mudou-se num conceito de 15
minutos tudo está conectado Quais são as
minhas prioridades antigos
segurança eu buscava minha realização
financeira as verdades mudou então agora
eu quero primeiro atenção a minha saúde
eu quero segurança da empregabilidade eu
quero Liberdade nesse meu trabalho eu
mandei livre eu quero poder me
desenvolver e treinar e por último
preocupação com o bem-estar da empresa
tem que se preocupar com o bem-estar
deixou de ser salário deixou de ser boa
nos deixou de ser essa necessidade
financeira que as pessoas tinham no
passado isso se aplica até o seu ativo
na Então você quer ter um escritório
escritório você quer ter um carro ou
você vai andar de transporte público
você vai de bicicleta porque é mais
sustentável você vai andar porque é mais
perto não conceito de cidade 15 minutos
e isso é possível de ser implementado né
final de contas né um transporte mais
sustentável no escritório mais Verde mas
amigável né empresas mais voltadas a
preocupação com a saúde mental e física
dos seus colaboradores depende desse
conceito de 15 minutos para que exista
né E aí eu queria enterrar aqui o
bate-papo por vocês dando uma provocação
daqui provocação que é essa vejam se faz
sentido essa minha afirmação né uma
pessoa que acorda todos os dias pelo
menos
1:15 antes de sair de casa para se
trocar e tudo mais e ela tem que mover
1500 kg de Aço movidos a 40 l de
gasolina para levar 80 Kg de carne e
muitas vezes para rodar não é poucos
quilômetros para pegar um pão da padaria
né 200 g de massa e faz todo o trajeto
de volta porque esse é o modal mais
utilizado pelas pessoas hoje nesse
deslocamento ineficiente que ainda polui
o ambiente a mesma coisa vale para os
escritórios a mesma coisa vale para as
casas do futuro então é a gente parar
sair um pouco né desse desse ponto a
qual estamos de é assim que sempre foi
feito e pensar como pode ser feito de
maneira mais sustentável como pode ser
feito de maneira mais ecológica mas
principalmente como pode ser feito
considerando as cidades do amanhã muito
obrigado
[Música]